الان نتحول الى نافذتنا العسكريه مع جلال
شهده في قراءه لاخر التطورات الميدانيه
جمال جمال كان لافتا اليوم الاخبار
العاجله الكثيره التي جاءت من كتائب
القسام عن استهداف اليات وجنود لقوات
الاحتلال في مناطق متفرقه من قطاع غزه
نحللها مع اللواء فياز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي ولكن اولا مع سلام
هذا يعكس ربما سلام حده الاشتباكات لاسما
في المناطق الشماليه حده الاشتباكات وتوسع
هذه الاشتباكات في اليوم ال 105 للحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه جمال جلال اذا
سنبدا من المنطقه الشماليه من شمال قطاع
غزه كانت مشتعله الى حد بعيد الاشتباكات
بدات منذ صباح اليوم منذ الساعات الاولى
لصباح اليوم ولكن بحلول ساعات المساء يمكن
ان نقول انها توسعت دائره الاشتباكات الى
حد بعيد لم تعد مقتصره فقط على حيي الدرج
والتفاح التان بدات فيهما منذ ساعات
الصباح بتنا نرى اشتباكات في جباليا ومخيم
جباليا الشيخ رضوان والشيخ عجلين وايضا
جنوب مدينه غزه هناك اشتباكات من مسافات
قصيره
وشاهدنا لقطات مصوره تظهر قرب الاشتباكات
والدليل استخدام الاسلحه الخفيفه في هذه
الاشتباكات وايضا القذائف
القصيره المدى واستخدام
الصواريخ عند استهداف الاليات الاسرائيليه
التي عادت وتوغلت منذ يوم امس من المنطقه
الشرقيه داخل قطاع غزه بعد اقل من 48 ساعه
كانت خلالها قد اخلت المنطقه الغربيه
والشماليه واتجهت الى المناطق الشرقيه الى
غلاف غزه وتمركزت عندها تقريبا عند الخط
الحدودي امس واليوم عدنا نرى توغلات
اسرائيليه بعض الصحف الامريك اميه ذا
نيويورك تايمز قالت او وصفت الوحدات التي
تتوغل الى داخل قطاع الى داخل المنطقه
الشماليه تحديدا بانها قوات خاصه للقيام
بعمليات سريعه ولكن ما رايناه اليوم ان
هناك اليات ايضا دخلت واليات ثقيله وكتائب
القسام وايضا سرايا القدس نفذت عمليات
استهداف على هذه الاليات الاسرائيليه
المتوغلة
جنود الوضع ايضا في المنطقه الوسطى لم يكن
اكثر هدوءا المنطقه الوسطى شهدت اشتباكات
منذ صباح اليوم ولكن حده هذه الاشتباكات
ارتفعت الى حد بعيد في ساعات بعد الظهر
واولى ساعات المساء مخيم البريش تحديدا
راينا فيه استهداف مباشر لكتائب
القسام لاليه اسرائيليه ومجموعه من الجنود
كانوا في صدد التوغل بشكل اعمق الى داخل
البري ولكن العمليه اجبرت القوه المهاجمه
على التراجع خلف الحدود الاساسيه للمخيم
يعني خارج الحدود وايضا شهدت المنطقه قصفا
مكثفا للطائرات
الاسرائيليه في الجنوب تبقى طبعا المنطقه
الجنوبيه هي الاكثر اشتعالا والاكثر حده
من حيث الاشتباكات وقرب الاشتباكات وايضا
تنوع طرق الاستهداف سنبدا من مدينه خان
يونس خان يونس المدينه تحاول القوات
الاسرائيليه منذ عده اسابيع الدخول الى
قلب مدينه خان يونس حتى الان لم تدخل الى
داخل المدينه ولكن ما الذي يجري تحاول
مرارا وتكرارا مهاجمه المدينه بطريقه اقوى
وباستخدام اسلحه مختلفه لا يقتصر استخدام
الاسلحه على المهاجمه بالدبابات او
بالاليات بل تتم ايضا في بعض الاحيان
الاستعانه بالطائرات الم مقاتله لاستهداف
بعض النقاط وبعض المناطق التي تريد القوات
الاسرائيليه اما محاوله التوغل الى داخلها
او على الاقل منع وقوع هجمات باتجاه
القوات التي تتمركز عند المناطق الشماليه
وعند المناطق الشماليه الشرقيه الى حد
بعيد عند منطقه منطقه البلديه في خان يونس
وه وهي تاخذ اسمها من الاسم الاداري
للمكان كانت تتمركز القوات الاسرائيليه
لبضعه ايام في فتره سابقه قبيل اعلان
الانسحاب الوحدات الاساسيه من داخل
المنطقه الجنوبيه لاستبدال هذه الوحدات
شنت كتائب القسام هجومات عليها وكانت
تهاجم المبنى تهاجم بقوه راجله بمعنى
عناصر من كتائب القسام شاهدنا فيديوهات
مصوره لهم يهاجمون الجنود المتمركزين داخل
هذا المب مبنى اليوم عادت القوات
الاسرائيليه وتمركزت فيه وايضا عادت كتائب
القسام واستهدفت هذا المبنى واستهدفت
القوه الاسرائيليه المتمركزه فيه ويبدو
انها ايضا اوقعت خسائر اسرائيل لا تكتفي
فقط في المنطقه الجنوبيه وهو ايضا تكتيك
ميداني استخدمته في مناطق اخرى لا تكتفي
فقط في الحصار او في محاوله التقدم او في
استخدام سلاح الطائرات على الاطلاق تحدد
بعض المناطق التي تقول و انها تشتبه بوجود
انفاق او بنيه تحتيه عسكريه تتبع لكتائب
المقاومه بعد ان تهاجم هذه المناطق
بالاليات وايضا تنفذ قصفا
بالطائرات على اي منطقه تشتبه بوجود هذه
الانفاق في هذه الحاله خانيونس في مناطق
اخرى كان هناك في بني سيله على سبيل
المثال وايضا شهدنا هذا في خزاعه هاجمت
الطيارات ثم تم الهجوم بالاليات الى
للسماح او لاتاحه توغل قوه الى داخل هذه
المناطق قوه راجله تقوم بتفخيخ المباني
وتفجيرها ونسفها بالكامل اليوم شهدنا في
خانيونس او الى الجنوب من خانيونس وفي
مناطق عده من القطاع الجنوبي في خان في
المنطقه الجنوبيه استهدافات من هذا النوع
كان هناك تفجير اك اكثر من مجمع سكني
وهدمت هذه المجمعات السكنيه بشكل شبه كامل
بعد هدم المجمعات السكنيه تعمد القوات
الاسرائيليه الى الدفع باليات ثقيله غالبا
جرافات لازاله هذا الحطام لماذا يزيل او
تزيل القوات المتوغلة
هي تتبع لهيئه الاركان
الاسرائيليه
وهذه لديها مركز دراسات يتبع لها قالت ان
الولايات المتحده حذر حذرت الجيش
الاسرائيلي من ان التوغل البري الى قطاع
غزه سيكون مساله صعبه ومعقده بسبب وجود
الانفاق وقالت ان الخطر لا يكمن فقط في ان
تستخدم الانفاق في عمليات هجوميه مباشره
ولا تستخدم ويمكن ان تستخدم اضافه الى
العمليات المباشره للعمليات للاختباء واو
ايه مهاجمه هذه القوات وفي حال عدم التمكن
استخدام الانفاق للهجوم قد تلعب الحطام او
ركام المباني دورا يساعد
القوات الغير نظاميه وفي هذه الحاله كتائب
القسام وكتائب المقاومه على الاختباء وشن
هجمات طبعا هذه الامور الميدانيه ومحاوله
شرح يعني ما يجري خاصه في الجنوب نعود
اليك جلال وتفصيلات اكثر مع اللواء الد
هناك تطورات في حيفا باخبار عاجله ورد
وردت قبل قليل مراسله الجزيره سقوط شضايا
صاروخ اعتراضي في مدينه طمره شمال حيفا
بعدها بقليل الجيش الاسرائيلي قال بان
سفرات الانذار دوت في حيفا بعد اطلاق
صاروخ اعتراضي نحو هدف جوي مشبوه والحادث
انتهى بحسب الجيش الاسرائيلي حتى ت ضح
المعلومات بعد قليل سنست وضح اكثر مع مع
مراسلينا ولكن قراءتك الاوليه قراء
الاوليه ان
هناك الارجح ان يكون طائره مسيره اطلقت من
جنوب لبنان
باتجاه حيفا والكرمل كما في بعض البيانات
التي اشارت واعتقد انا يعني لا اقول تجاوز
للخط الاحمر لانه هذا الخط تم تجاوزه اكثر
من مره وارسلت اكثر من طائره وكانت تسقط
فوق البحر الى غير ذلك لكن انه ياتي من من
وجهه نظري من باب رد الاعتبار لانه كانت
هناك اختراقات اسرائيليه جسيمه جدا سواء
الشيخ العاروري او قائد
الفي وحده الر الرضوان وحده الرضوان وكان
اكبر قائد عسكري يستهدف وبالتالي كانت
الردود اطلاق 62 صاروخ على ما اذكر وكان
معظمها سقط في مناطق غير ماهوله اذا لا بد
من ان يكون هناك رد في شيء من الاعتبار
كتوز هذا الامر لكن اعتقد ان الامر انتهى
وسيكون خلاص يعني يعني تعتقد ان ان الهدف
المشبوه الذي تتحدث عنه الجيش الاسرائيلي
اطلق من لبنان اتوقع انه طائره مسيره
اطلقت من جنوب لبنان كم تبتعد حيفا عن
جنوب لبنان هو تقريبا الخط النهائي حوالي
20 م 20 م وعاده تطلق من جنوب لبنان وتاخذ
مسار فوق البحر وتدخل من اتجاه البحر ويتم
التعامل معها لكن هذا المدى تقريبا او هذا
الخط يصل الى حوالي 20 م اللي هو الخط
المعتمد الان هو انتقل من 5 الى 8 م من
حيث القصف الصاروخي
والمدفعي وبالتالي هذا الخط فقط ال 20 م
تم تجاوزه مرتين او ثلاث مرات سابقا
معظمها بطائرات او كلها بطائرات مسيره طيب
تحديد الجيش الاسرائيلي بحسب ما قال بانه
هدف جوي مشبوه برايك لماذا لماذا يستخدم
هذه المصطلحات هف جوي مشبوه لا يعرف ما هو
حتى الان لا يعني لا توجد معلومات فنيه
كامله الان اذا
اي يعني طائره مسيره هناك عشرات الانواع
من الطائرات المسيره هل هي طائره مسيره من
صناع سنع حزب الله هل هي طائره 36
الايرانيه شاهد التي تستخدم في اوكرانيا
وبالتالي اذا ما تيقنت من نوع الطائره قد
تكون لانه ايران لديها طائرات تصل 2000 كم
تطير لمده 36 ساعه اذا كان يعني رمزيه الع
العمل العمل انتهى ام لكن رمزيه العمل اذا
كانت طائره قادمه من ايران سواء من العمق
السوري او العراقي تعني شيء واذا كانت من
جنوب لبنان تعني شيء اخر لانه جنوب لبنان
حزب الله في تماس يومي وبالتالي متوقع ان
يطلق صواريخ متوقع ان يطلق لكن ايران لا
لكن لاحظ كان هناك تصريح اعتقد لنتنياهو
عندما سئل حول الملف النووي الايراني او
انه احتماليه توجيه ضربه كانه يعني اجاب
بضباط
نحن في حاله اشتباك يعني بمعنى اخر نحن
ننفذ عمليات في العمق الايراني فهلا هذه
يعني الان هذا الجسم المشبوه قد يوضع امام
احتمالين ما لم تاتينا المعلومات الاقنيه
هل هو رد على تصريح نتياهو ام هو رد على
االحل استفهم اكثر مازن ابراهيم مدير مكتب
الجزيره في بيروت ينضم الينا طبعا من جنوب
لبنان وفي الجليل الاعلى جفارا البديري
شمال اسرائيل جيفارا هل هناك معلومات
اضافيه عن ما ذكره بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي
هدف جوي مشبوه وبان الحادث قد
انتهى هذا فقط ما ادلى به الجيش
الاسرائيلي في بيان مقتضب ان صافرات
الانذار دوت
فور اطلاق صاروخ مضاد او صاروخ من القبه
الحديديه اتجاه جسم مشبوه في الجو لم يتم
الاعلان هل ان ما كان صاروخ ام كان بالفعل
طائره مسيره ام كان تشخيص خاطئ حتى وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه خلال الخمس دقائق
الماضيه هي في حاله تضارب لا تعرف ما الذي
حدث لماذا دوت صافرات الانذار اصلا في
حيفا وهذه هي المره الثانيه التي تدوي
فيها صافرات الانذار في حيفا وجبل الكرمل
منذ بدايه الحرب ولكن نذكر فقط انه ساعات
صباح هذا اليوم ايضا كان هناك اعلان من
قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه تم اعتراض
مسيره اطلقت من داخل الاراضي اللبنانيه
اخترقت المجال الجوي الاسرائيلي من ناحيه
البحر وتم اعتراضها عند عكا اي شمال حيفا
وكانت قريبه وفق القناه الثانيه عش
الاسرائيليه انها كانت اتجاه ومصو اتجاه
موقع عسكري في حيفا اذا ينظر باهميه شديده
وبالغه الحذر اتجاه هذا التشخيص الجديد
ولكن ايضا في ذات الوقت هناك تصعيد ل ال
اللهجه السياسيه والعسكريه والامنيه
الاسرائيليه اتجاه حزب الله ما ورد على
هيئه البث الاذا هيئه البث الاسرائيليه
الرسميه بان رساله ارسلت من اسرائيل
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه بانه ان لم
تتراجع قوه الرضوان من الجنوب اللبناني اي
الى ما بعد الليطاني فاننا سنتجه نحو
الحرب والعمليه العسكريه الموسعه ونذكر
ايضا ان اي اليوم
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي جالانت كان قد حذر
بلهجه تصعيديه ان اسرائيل لا تريد الحرب
ولكن ان لم يتم وقف كل العمليات العسكريه
من قبل حزب الله فان الحرب قادمه لا محاله
وان انزلقت الامور الى تلك الناحيه فسيتم
العمل معها كسكين اي بقوه كبيره اذا نتحدث
عن تصريحات سياسيه وعسكريه مرتفعه الوتيره
وفي المقابل في الميدان ايضا ارتفاع في
الوتيره لماذا الاهميه تجاه حيفا لانه ان
تم ضرب حيفا معناه ان تصعيد التوتر الان
بلغ اشده ولا نعرف الى اين
سيصل طيب
اي هناك اخبار عاجله الان هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه تقول بان اسرائيل تحذر في
رساله لواشنطن
من شن عمل عسكري اذا لم تبعد قوه الرضوان
عن الحدود الشماليه اذا هذا تحذير جديد من
اسرائيل وكما قلت قبل قليل جيفار البديري
ولكن لنستفد اكثر معك مازن ابراهيم ما
امكانيه ان يكون هذا الهدف الجوي المشبوه
الذي اشار اليه الجيش الاسرائيلي في سماء
حيفا ان يكون اطلق فعلا من جنوب
لبنان في الواقع جلال بالنسبه لاطلاق اي
اي صاروخ او مسيره من جنوب لبنان نتحدث عن
القطاع الغربي المتاخم للجليل الغربي في
اسرائيل وبالتالي باتجاه عكا وحيفا
انطلاقا من هنا نحن لم نرصد امرين لم نرصد
الامر الاول هو اطلاق الصواريخ من القطاع
الغربي من جنوب لبنان باتجاه هذا هذه
المنطقه اي باتجاه عكا او باتجاه حيفا هذا
امر اول الامر الثاني عاده عندما نعم حيفا
الامر الثاني عندما يتم اطلاق صواريخ او
مسيرات من هذه المنطقه ثمت مواقع لقوات
اليونيفل وهي تطلق في تلك اللحظات صفارات
الانذار بمعنى اننا كنا نرصد طيله الفتره
الماضيه كلما تم اطلاق صواريخ من جنوب
لبنان او مسيرات باتجاه الجليل الغربي فان
المركز الرئيسي لقوات الطوارئ اليونيفل
المتواجد في منطقه الناقوره كان يشغل
صفارات الانذار ايضا هذا الامر لم يتم
رصده خلال الساعه الماضيه اي عمليا ان
رادارات قوات اليونيفيل لم ترصد اطلاق
صواريخ او مسيرات هذا امر الامر الثاني
نحن كفرق صحفيه في هذه المنطقه وايضا في
منطقه القطاع الغربي من جنوب لبنان لم
نرصد اطلاق صواريخ وبالتالي فرضيه
الصواريخ غير منطقيه وغير وارده اما اطلاق
المسيرات فان هذا الامر يحصل دائما من قبل
حزب الله ولكن هنا دعني اذكرك بامر ما خ
حصل خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين فصائل عراقيه
كانت اعلنت سابقا بانها اطلقت صاروخ وصفته
بانه تحت مسمى الارقب باتجاه حيفا هذا
الامر حصل قبل نحو سبعه ايام ايضا قبلها
باسبوعين جرى الحديث عن اطلاق مسيره
باتجاه حقل كاريش حقل كاريش النفطي ايضا
الذي يقع في قباله الجليل الغربي في البحر
وبالتالي الاحتمالات مفتوحه والاحتمالات
متعدده سواء اطلقت مسيره من جنوب لبنان او
جرى اطلاقها سواء من سوريا او من غيرها من
المناطق باتجاه تلك المنطقه وتحديدا حيفا
خليج حيفا وايضا عكا انطلاقا من هذه
المعادله يمكن ان نقول بان الامر حتى هذه
اللحظه مازال مفتوحا لا يمكن تاكيد بان
ثمه هدف اطلق من لبنان باتجاه تلك المنطقه
ولكن هنا لابد من ربط هذه التطورات بما
حصل في السياسه كلام نعيم قاسم قبل نحو
ساعتين كان واضحا بان حزب الله يستعد الى
ما وصفه بالعدوان الاسرائلي الذي له بدايه
ولا نهايه له وبان الحزب جاهز لكل
الاحتمالات وبانه وفي حال فتحت هذه الجبهه
بناء على التهديدات الاسرائيليه سواء تلك
التي اطلقها جالانت او اطلقها نتنياهو
بالامس فان حزب الله جاهز وهنا لابد من
الاشاره مجددا جلال الى ان نعيم قاسم
وقبله الامين العام لحزب الله ربطا تهدئه
هذه الجبهه ووقف الحرب وفق ما ما قاله وقف
الحرب في الجبهه الجنوبيه للبنان وايضا في
المنطقه مربوط بانتهاء العدوان الاسرائيلي
في قطاع غزه وبالتالي الامور متطوره عند
هذه الجبهه وهنا ايضا ربطا بكل ما شاهدناه
خلال هذا اليوم جلال من غارات عنيفه واكثر
من 16 غاره تم اطلاقها من قبل اسرائيل على
طول هذا الخط الحدودي لجنوب لبنان ابقى
معك مازن واعيد بالخبر العاجل الذي بثي
اناه هيئه البث الاسرائيليه تقول بان
اسرائيل تحذر في رساله لواشنطن من شن عمل
عسكري اذا لم تبعد قوه الرضوان قوه
الرضوان هي طبعا قوه في حزب الله عن حدود
الشمال لماذا قوه الرض الرضوان ما مازن ما
هي هذه القوه ما الذي تشكله بالنسبه لحزب
الله وبالنسبه لاسرائيل
في الواقع قوه الرضوان او وحده الرضوان هي
قوات النخبه لدى حزب الله وهنالك انتشار
لهذه القوه على طول هذا الخط الحدودي وكان
دائما هنالك خشيه اسرائيليه من ان هذه
القوه التي تعتبر من نخبه مقاتلي حزب الله
بانها قد تعمد الى محاوله اختراق هذا الخط
الحدودي باتجاه الم طنات من هنا كان
التحذير الدائم من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بضروره ابعاد قوات الرضوان عن
الخط الامامي للحدود اللبنانيه الجنوبيه
هذا الامر وما تم ما ورد الان عبر هذا
العاجل الذي تحدث عنه جلال كان قد وصل الى
لبنان عندما جاء الموفد الامريكي هوكست هو
ابلغ من التقاهم من مسؤولين لبنانيين
بضروره تراجع حزب الله عن الخط الحدودي
لان اسرائيل تعتزم تنفيذ عمل ما اذا ما
استمر الوضع على ما هو عليه وذلك ربطا
بتهجير عشرات الاف المستوطنين من
المستوطنات التي تقع على كامل الخط
الحدودي ولكن بالنسبه لحزب الله ابعاد قوه
الرضوان غير مطروح على الاطلاق ليس فقط
قوه الرضوان ولكن البنيه التحتيه لقواعده
العسكريه المنتشره في طول هذه المنطقه هو
يعتبر بانه لا يمكن البحث بتطبيق القرار
1701 وانسحاب قوات حزب الله الى ما وراء
نهر اللط طالما ان اسرائيل لم تنفذ القرار
1701 وتحديدا ما يتعلق بالانسحاب من مزارع
شبعه المحتله من تلال كفر شوبه من منطقه
خراج الماري او المحيطه ببلده الماري
اللبنانيه او ما يعرف ببلده الغجر
بالاضافه الى التراجع عن النقاط التي
يتحفظ عنها لبنان على طول خط الازرق وتبلغ
ويبلغ عدد هذه النقاط 13 نقطه يتحفظ لبنان
ويعتبر بان اسرائيل ما زالت تحتل على طول
هذا الخط انطلاقا من هذه المعادله التي تم
ابلاغها ليس فقط للموفد الامريكي ولكن
ايضا لجوزيف بوريل عندما وصل الى لبنان
خلال الفتره الماضيه تم ابلاغه من قبل حزب
الله بان الحرب ستستمر عد الحدود الجنوبيه
للبنان طالما ان العدوان في غزه مستمر
وايضا تطبيق القرار 1701 واي حديث عن
انسحاب قوات حزب الله هو امر لا يمكن
البحث به اليوم قبل انتهاء المواجهات
والحرب في غزه شكرا لكم مازن في رميش جنوب
لبنان وجيفارا في الجلد للاعلى شمال
اسرائيل لواء دويري لاخت بال الجبهه
الشماليه لاسرائيل قبل ان تحول مره جديده
الى الى غزه كيف تفهم تصعيد نبره
التصريحات اخيرا لجلن لنتنياهو فيما يتعلق
بالمواجهات مع حزب الله يعني نتنياهو جلنت
يواجهوا ازمه حقيقيه فيما يتعلق في غزه
غزه وبالتالي انهاء الحرب في غزه دون
تحقيق نصر وعد به
لمجتمع الاسرائيلي تعني النهايه الحتميه
اها سياسيا وربما الى السجن فيما يتعلق
بنتنياهو وبالتالي الكل يتحدث ان اطاله
امد الحرب من اجل اهداف سياسيه واهداف
شخصيه للبقاء في الحكم يعني هي عمليه هروب
الى الامام وبالتالي وبالتالي قد يلجا
نتنياهو وجلن لانه الان جلنت يعتبر احد
المتهمين الرئيسيين في محكمه لاهاي لانه
هو الذي يخضع تحت
بند البعد الانساني الجرام ضد الانسانيه
اذا ما يمنع ان يتم اعاده خلط الاوراق
بتوسيع الجبهه و كنا نقول دائما تصعيد
منضبط لكن اللهجه الاسرائيليه الان اكثر
الى التطرف طيب اخيرا طبعا هذه الحدود
اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه حيف هنا قلت بانها
تبعد 20 كيلو عن الحدود بغض
النظر من اطلق هذا الهدف ف الجوي المشبوه
كما يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي حتى الان لا
معلومات مازن قال بانه لا رصد
لاق بغض النظر من اطلق هذا الهدف المشبوه
ما الذي يعنيه بالنسبه لاسرائيل محاولات
استهداف حيفا يعني الان دعنا نقول
المحاوله فشلت وبالتالي لن يكون هناك رده
فعل لكن هي تاخذ في بعد انه نوع من التحدي
انا انا اهدد بانني عند الاستعداد اذا لم
تسحب مجموعه الرضوان الى ما انا عد للذهاب
الى الحرب الخطاب من حزب الله تبدا ولكنك
لا تستطيع ان تنهي قد تعلن الحرب ولكنني
انا من يقرر انهاء الحرب اذا هناك لهجه
تصعيديه منكل الجانبين وبالتالي تقع هذه
الاشارات والحديث عن هذا عن هذا الجسم غير
المحدد ضمن الاطار التصعيدي ولكن نشعر
دائما بالنسبه لاسرائيل ان حيفا يعني مهمه
بالنسبه لها ولماذا مستودعات الامونيوم
مستع مستودعات الامونيوم الامونيوم موجود
وبالتالي كان في عام ما بعد عام ال 86 هي
لم ت لم تستهدف لانه كان حزب الله كان انا
هكذا ارع انه وضع خط احمر من تلقاء ذاته
حتى لا يهاجم هدفا تكون تداعيات استخدامه
اي كبيره جدا ولكن تم تشخيص هذا الهدف
تحديدا على لسان احد مسؤولي حزب الله واضح
تماما بخصوص غزه لاحظنا اليوم عدد كبير من
الاستهدافات من كتائب القسام اخبار عاجله
وردت على شاشه الجزيره لاستهداف متكرره
قنص استهداف ايضا لاليات عسكريه من بينها
ميركافا وايضا استهداف جنود ماذا تقرا
بتطور وتوسع رقعه المواجهه بين الجيش
الاسرائيلي دعنا نعود الى المنطقه
الشماليه المنطقه الشماليه لا نقول شهدت
هدوءا ولكنه انخفاض
وتيره القتال خاصه بعد انسحاب وانكفاء
الفرق المتواجده الى الشمال والى الشرق
الان هناك ثلاثه نقاط ارتكاز لقوات جيش
الاحتلال وهي في وضعيه الاستعداد القتالي
يعني ليست هي في فتره اعاده تاهيل بالمطلق
يتم اعاده التاهيل ولكن هي بوضعيه استعداد
قتالي الان خلال الفتره الماضيه استمرت
الاستهدافات لكن بالمدفعيه بالطائرات كوات
كابتور بطائرات
الباشي ويوجد قوات في في وادي غزه بحدود
لوائين من غرب جحر الديك وحتى
الان لم يكن لدى المقاومه القدره على الرد
الا في بعدين محددين و بتباعد زمني اما
اطلاق قذائف الهاون او اطلاق رشقات من
الصواريخ على غلاف غزه ه يعني لم لم يعود
استخدام الهاون والصواريخ اداه ردع
وبالتالي لا بد فيديو اطلاق الصواريخ
فيديو اطلاق الصواريخ لو سمحتم هي صواريخ
1007 هذه سرايا القدس هذه من منطقه البريج
من شرق البريج الان هذه قذائف هاون تطلق
ليست اليخ هذه كتاب القسام هذه هاون نعم
هذه كذاب القسام تطلق القذائف الهاون 2
الان هناك ثلاث انواع 120 80 60 اوكي
وبالتالي حسب المتاح واللقطات
هذ ملم 8 م هي عندما نقول 120 80 قطر الفو
قطر الفو بالتالي المدى يكون اقصر عندما
يكون 80 الان ال 120 اكثر فاعليه واقصى
مدى وال 80 ياتي بعده وال6 يديي بعده
وهناك كمان ما هو اقل من ال 60 وبالتالي
يقل المت ويقل التاثير لانه الان قدره
الدفع الحشوه الدافعه اقل لانه حجم
القذيفه اقل وبالتالي حتى الراس المتفجر
وزن المتفجرات اقل ولكنه يبقى استخدام ضد
الاهداف اللينه طيب يعني لاحظ الان هناك
افرق الحجم في الم المره الاولى كان الوضع
اكبر نعم اصغ هذا اصغر نعم اي يعني ما ما
ال ما الذي يفرض
استخدام صواريخ
اصغر طبيعه الهدف اين موقع الهدف المسافه
يعني اذا كان الهدف قريب واستطيع ان
استخدم العيار الاقل استخدمه لانه العيار
الاكبر احتاجه اكثر في في في مواقف ثانيه
ه هذه 107 الان التي نتابعها الان سنشاهد
107 كم مدى
100 من خمسه الى لا رجعنا للهاون اه لا
تابعنا 17 107 المدى من 5 الى 8 م م ووزن
الراس المتفجر 3 غرام الوزن
الاجمالي 18 كغم ويستخدم هو حتى تقريبا
الذي شاهدنا هو توجيه بصري لا بال لا
بالاشعه الليزر ولا بالاشعه تعت الحمراء
توجيه بصري توجيه بصري لانه يعني اذا اذا
تم اعاده الفيلم ستشاهد سنبه قاعده
الاطلاق خاصه في بدر واحد خص يعني قاعده
الاطلاق حتى في صواريخ 107 كانت قاعده
رباعيه وبالتالي حتى توجيهها يمكن ان يكون
اكثر دقه لكن في حاله الصاروخ الاخر بدر
لا كان الوضع يعني هذه الان 107 وبدر واحد
ضم مع وهنا بدر ليس بدر ايراني او البدر
الحوثي هذا هو الي تحدث عنه ال هي لاحظ هي
قاعده اربع صواريخ الان يركب بالفيوز هلا
بعد ان يبعد ايده نلاحظ الفيوز
حلقه التامين اذا
لاحظت الان بجهز يعود يفك حلقه التامين
وبالتالي يتم الاطلاق والاطلاق كهربائي
لاحظ الاسلاك الاطلاق كهربائي ولكن واضح
انه بدائي بدائي التوجيه بدائي لا سنرى في
اللقطه الثانيه اكثر بدائيه اها اها يعني
هذا هو المتاح هذا هو
الموجود و ما الذي يستهدفه عاده هذا هذا
الصرو يا سي يستهدف تجمعات المشاه تجمعات
الالات غير ذلك يعني فعال على التح لاحظ
هنا لاحظ الاطلاق على ماذا يرتكز على سيبه
صح بس بدي اشير لنقطه رغم بدائيه المظهر
لكن هناك مخاطره عاليه جدا للوصول الىه
النقطه هو من اين اتى من الانفاق خرج
ويحمل ذلك الصاروخ وينتقل الى مكان ل مخفي
مؤمن حتى يطلق هذا هذا الصاروخ اذا لاح
حجم المخاطره والتضحيه لتا لطلاق هذا
الصاروخ شكرا لك اللواء فيز ويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي